bonjour bonjour et bienvenue dans sens
public nous sommes le jeudi 11 janvier
et nous sommes ensemble pour 1h30 de
débat et de décryptage alors on prend
les mêmes et on recommence à l'heure où
je vous parle l'Agence France Presse
vient dégrainer quelques noms du futur
gouvernement Atal et le premier
renseignement c'est que plusieurs poids
lourds de l'équipe borne sont confirmés
alors nous ferons le point sur les
visages qui entoureront le nouveau
Premier ministre mais aussi sur les
chantiers qui l'attendent à quelle
priorité à quelle forme doit-il s'ateler
ce sera le thème de notre premier débat
dans la seconde partie de notre émission
nous nous pencherons sur la situation en
Iran après le double attentat qui a fait
une centaine de morts et plus de 300
blessés le 3 janvier dernier quel jeu
trouble joue l'Iran dans l'embrasement
au Proche Orient et puis le conflit
israélo-palestinien peut-il entraver sa
stratégie de normalisation ce sera le
thème de notre second débat mais tout de
suite place au premier thème
le gouvernement ce nouveau gouvernement
ou un gouvernement de continuité et puis
peut-être de nouvelles réformes à lancer
en tout cas une nouvelle méthode à
trouver et puis surtout une élection à
remporter voici à quoi pourrait
ressembler la feuille de route du
nouveau Premier ministre Gabriel hatal
on fait le point avec Samia dechir un
premier ministre jeune populaire et très
médiatique le profil de Gabriel Attal a
fait de lui le mieux placé pour mener la
bataille des européennes de juin
prochain face à Jordan bardellate de
liste du rassemblement national c'est le
premier chantier qui l'attend et il est
très mal embarqué pour la majorité
présidentielle 10 points derrière
l'extrême droite dans les sondages on a
là enfin quelqu'un qui fait de la
politique quelqu'un qui sait gérer des
campagnes électorales donc sans doute ça
va être ce qui va occuper et préoccuper
Gabriel c'est de conduire une majorité
dans le cadre de ces élections
européennes contrairement à Elisabeth
borne Gabriel Attal n'a pas de réforme
explosive comme celle des retraites à
faire passer mais sa mission a rien d'un
long fleu tranquille pour autant avec un
taux de chômage remonté à
7,4% honorer la promesse macroniste du
plein emploi passera par une délicate
réforme du marché du travail et sans
doute un durcissement des règles de
l'assurance chômage pour les siors le
tout dans un contexte budgétaire plombé
par la dette publique qui annonce
probablement des arbitrages difficiles
que nous devons trouver au minimum au
minimum 12 milliards d'euros d'économie
pour
2025 appelons donc un chat un chat en
matière de finances publi le plus dur
est devant nous Gabriel Atal hérite
aussi de la loi sur la fin de vie sans
oublier les chantiers qu'il a lui-même
lancé à l'éducation national réforme du
brevet dès 2024 groupe de niveau au
collège et pour tout cela il lui faudra
composer avec une majorité fragilisée
par la douloureuse adoption de la loi
immigration leschantier de de Gabriel
tal on en parle ce soir avec mes invités
bonsoir Christelle crappel bonsoir vous
êtes directrice générale de BVA opinion
à vos côté Pablo Pillot Vivien rédacteur
en chef de la revue regard j'accueille
aussi Christophe deog vous êtes
historien et président du conseil
scientifique de la Fondation pour
l'innovation politique plus connu sous
le nom de Fondapol et puis notre
éditorialiste am tranui qui
m'accompagnera tout au long de cette
émission alors je le disais dans
l'introduction de cette émission
quelques noms sont tombés
sur le les les membres du nouveau
gouvernement àal et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'ils sont pas
forcément nouveaux je vous les donne
comme ça Gérald armanin reconduit à
l'intérieur Bruno Le Maire reconduit à
Bercy Éric Dupont Moretti reconduit à la
justice Sébastien Lecornu reconduit aux
armées et puis une nouvelle porte-parole
Prisc tevno qui s'occupait jusqu'à
présent du service national universel
ces premiers noms ces poids lourds de
l'équipe borne qui sont reconduits
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire Christophe
deog ben ça m'inspire que c'est quand
même un sujet alors au-delà évidemment
de de l'agitation politicienne c'est un
sujet important dans la mesure où où il
permet de mesurer dans quelle mesure le
gouvernement Atal est vraiment un
gouvernement de régénération
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'il a emporté
de la continuité de la résistance des
préférences du président ou de
l'évidence souci de renouveau du nouveau
Premier ministre bah pour l'instant pas
beaucoup de renouveau sur les quat noms
que je viens de vous donner on est bien
d'accord et je pense que ça n'est pas
forcément de très bonne augure pour lui
notamment vis-à-vis de l'opinion
c'est-à-dire que quelle que soit la
qualité des des poids lourds REC
conduits on voit très bien que des
décisions ont déjà été prises très tôt
et des je dirais des accords directs
entre le président et certains ministres
je crois que tout le monde sait qu'ils
se sont vus avant même la nomination de
Gabriel hatal d'ailleurs et on sent bien
qu'il y a eu des conditions posé de
maintien Gérald armmanin même lui fait
lui-même savoir qu'il serait maintenu
quand même ass assez curieux bref je
crois que le nouveau Premier ministre
commence vous avez parlé d'un agenda
très lourd mais il commence en plus à B
avis avec un handicap politique Pablo
pot Vivien c'est de la continuité c'est
de la stabilité on pourrait dire aussi
ou c'est un handicap comme le dit
Christophe deog moi je pense plutôt que
c'est c'est un handicap mais je pense
qu'il faut il faut raisonner dans dans
l'autre sens il faut il faut se demander
en fait qui a envie de monter dans le
bateau Macron aujourd'hui à un peu plus
de 3 ans de la fin de son 2e les
derniers mandat ben absolument personne
en gros il y a deux choix c'est ou bien
vous allez chercher des politiques mais
pour élargir ce que ce qu'est
aujourd'hui le macronisme donc si vous
voulez élargir bah faut aller chercher
soit à gauche c'està-dire du côté du
Parti socialiste il en est absolument h
de question soit du côté des LR mais qui
il en est absolument hors de question
aussi puisque les LR n'ont aucun intérêt
politiquement à rentrer au gouvernement
et à faire une alliance quelle qu'elle
soit avec avec le le gouvernement vous
parlez là vous parlez là d'une alliance
d'appareil entre le parti des
républicains et le gouvernement on peut
avoir des figures LR oui mais ça c'est
oui mais cette technique là le problème
c'est que cette technique là elle est
elle est réchauffée c'est-à-dire que
depuis Nicolas Sarkozi qui est allé
chercher des gens à à gauche quelques
ministres de gauche on a bien vu que
derrière lorsque vous faites rentrer un
ministre de gauche enfin dit de gauche
dans un gouvernement de droite bah il
devient de droite et il est incapable de
tenir de Ten dire sa sa ligne de gauche
c'est la même chose avec le macronisme
vous faites rentrer voyez Gabriel Atal
et Gérald daran on parle beaucoup de
leur rivalité mais au fond ils disent
exactement la même chose quand j'ai
écouté euh Gabriel hatal sur le pon de
Matignon ou alors en déplacement avec
Gérald daranin tout ce qui est sorti de
sa bouche Gérald daranin aurait pu le le
signer et le contresigner mais juste il
y a les politiques mais il y a aussi la
Cé civile et la Cé civile aujourd'hui
lorsque vous faites partie euh lorsque
vous êtes une personnalité je ne sais
pas moi de de la culture ou de
l'économie quel intérêt vous avez à
rejoindre un bateau qui est déjà en
train de prendre l'eau que tous les
commentateurs politique tous les
observateurs de la vie politique mais
même beaucoup beaucoup de citoyens se
disent mais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
c'est on comprend pas le cap on comprend
pas où il vont et on sait très bien que
il va foncer que que le Titanic est en
train de foncer dans l'iceberg donc
personne ne veut monter dedans donc
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il est obligé de
reprendre les même et puis
éventuellement il va élargir les les
portefeuilles des des des des actuels
enfin des sortants des ministres
sortants alors il est possible queon
connaisse d'abord le nom des ministres
et puis dans un second temps celui des
ministres délégués et puis des
secrétaires d'État Christelle crappelet
ces quatre noms dont j'ai parlé Éric
Dupont moritier la justice Gérald Haran
àintérieur Bruno Lemer Bery Sébastien
Lecornu aux armées est-ce que l'exécutif
a gardé les stars ou est-ce qu'il a
gardé les boulets il a gardé point vue
de l'opinion publique d'un point de vue
de l'opinion il a gardé les personnes
les plus identifiées parce qu'il y en a
pas tant que ça de ministres qui sont
identifiés reconnus par les Français il
y avait Gabriel Atal incontestablement
le plus populaire il est accueilli
positivement dans l'opinion en tout cas
pour pour le moment et les autres autres
qui sont bien identifiés ce sont Bruno
Lemaire et Géral Darmanin quand on a
notre petit classement de de baromètres
des personnalités ils sont dans le top 5
donc voilà c'est ce sont les personnes
les plus identifié par les fr identifié
ça veut pas dire populaire non ils ont
alors ils ont quand même ce qu'on
appelle nous chez nous une code
d'influence assez élevé donc voilà ils
sont en tout cas ils sont plutôt bien
perçus mais pas en majorité en revanche
ils sont très bien perçus de l'électorat
d'Emmanuel Macron des sympathisants LR
donc ce sont quand même des que soit
Bruno memer ou Géral Amin des personnes
qui ont du poids politique et qui sont
appréciés dans le cœur de l'électorat
Éric DUP Moretti il a quel trait d'image
comment est-ce que il est moins
identifié quand même il est moins il est
moins connu et moins identifié mais
après il faudrait voilà regarder plus
précisément sa sa structure de de
popularité je pense qu'il voilà il est
moins populaire que ne le sont je parle
bien là auprès des sympathisants
Renaissance ELR Bruno le ma ouou
gérardmanin alors est-ce que la
continuité c'est forcément un handicap
pour reprendre votre expression de tout
à l'heure Christophe de je pense à Bery
notamment où la France se caractérisait
pendant des années par une espèce de
valse des ministres au poids que nos
partenaires européens disaient on ne
sait jamais à qui on va s'adresser là
Bruno Le Maire est en poste depuis
maintenant 6 ans et demi c'est plutôt un
facteur de stabilité ou vous y voyez
pour je parle pour la politique
économique française ou c'est ou c'est
un handicap c'est plus quand même un
facteur de c'est un facteur de
crédibilité Bruno Le Maire n'est pas
discuté au niveau européen il a avantage
aussi de parler l'allemand si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire en matière
financière ça n'est pas inutile et il a
un bilan qui est considéré comme alors
malgré la dette malgré beaucoup de
choses il est considéré comme crédible à
Bruxelles et surtout et surtout à
Francfort j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus
et donc évidemment dans l'intérêt
d'Emmanuel Macron de le garder est-ce
qu'il est dans l'intérêt de Bruno le de
rester ça j'en suis moins sûr parce que
Bruno Leem on le rappelle a des vues sur
2027 vous pensez qu' fait une erreur
vous pensez qu'il fait une erreur en
restant ber en même temps c'est c'est
très délicat vous savez ce sont des
paris sur l'avenir je suis moins sûr que
c'est plus important certainement pour
Macron et peut-être pour la France aussi
du point de la crédibilité surtout que
pourquoi je dis ça c'est que on en
reparlera sans doute quand on évoquera
les chantiers c'est que l'horizon
économique Pablo parlait justement des
difficultés du cap de l'équipage mais le
cap va être difficile à tenir dans un
horizon qui va pas qui ne s'arrange pas
c'est-à-dire que vous savez on attend
les résultats du dernier semestre
2023 le 3è était négatif on est
peut-être entré en récession enfin en
tout cas c'est pas du tout impossible
l'inflation a baissé mais elle reste
importante et puis le chômage commence à
remonter un peu le chômage commence à
remonter et tout de suite déjà une seule
chose un dossier qui se présente là dans
l'immédiia c'est la hausse du prix de
l'électricité plus 10 % comme le demande
Bery donc le monsieur qui on rappelle au
télpectur ur que c'est ce qu'on appelle
la fin du bouclier tarifaire toutes les
mesures qui avaient été mises en place
pour alléger les taxes sur l'électricité
et que la fin de cette allègement va
proposer va provoquer pardon une hausse
mécanique des tarifs de l'ordre de 10 %
à partir du mois de février à moins que
le premier ministre n'en décide
autrement mais ça pour l'instant scén
très rapide hein ça c'est un test absolu
Bery a a son sa religion sur la question
euh les Français vous imaginez les gens
auxquels vous parlez à l'instant ont
tous une facture d'électricité
que va faire Gabriel àal par rapport à
ça
oui moi je rebondir sur ce que disait
Olivier c'estàdire que christhe
Christophe pardon sur ce que disait
Christophe il il se positionnait par
rapport au à des indicateurs
macroéconomiques que regardent à la fois
les bourses les agences de notation et
éventuellement no nos partenaires
européens et et mondiaux et c'est tout à
fait juste que de ce point de
vue-là Bruno Le Maire est un facteur de
stabilité en revanche du point de vue
des citoyens et des citoyennes qu'est-ce
qu'il voit il voit la hausse de
l'électricité et vous avez dit c'est la
fin du boucer tarifaire et c'est
mécanique non c'est pas mécanique c'est
un choix politique en fait j'ai dit que
le premierunist pouvait inverser a un
effet mécanique de Haus ça que je dis il
y a effet mécanique de hausse parce que
ils ont fait le choix de d'augmenter une
taxe qui pèse sur électricité une taxe
spécifique qui pèse sur l'électricité
donc de taxer la consommation des
Français et des Françaises plutôt que et
c'est ce que je c'est ce que c'est ce
que dit la gauche c'est ce que propose
la gauche d'augmenter des impôts
progressifs ce choix qui est fait par
Bruno Lemer depuis 6 ans en fait de
taper sur les impôts progressifs de
tasser les impôts progressifs ou de
négliger les impôts progressif pour ne
taxer que la consommation c'est un choix
de droite qui est décidé depuis 6 ans et
qui aujourd'hui à mon sens nous mène
dans le mur et les Français et les
Français le voient c'estàdire que il y a
le choix effectivement des agences de
notation et de nos partenaires européens
mais aussi ch des Français et des
Françaises et les Français et les
Françaises le Bruno demande c'est devenu
une blague sur les réseaux sociaux Bruno
demande au aux grands de la de la grande
distribution et de la de la production
agroalimentaire sil pouvait un peu
tasser les prix et puis finalement bah
ni la grande distribution ni les les
producteurs de alimentaires ne tassent
les prix là les Français le voient les
Français ils vont faire les courses et
ils voient très bien que Ben l'inflation
ils la prennent de plein fouis et que en
plus leur salaire n'a pas augmenté en
conséquence mais il voit aussi que les
impôts ont augmenté exactement Chris
rappel juste les Français attendait du
changement de ce remaniment ou ils s'en
fichaient un peu de ce remaniment bah un
peu des deux mais quand on leur a
demandé comment il réagissaiit à la
nomination de Gabriel àal ça permet un
peu de relativiser les choses 51 % nous
disent qu'ils sont indifférents donc
voilà même si ça passionne plein de gens
et les Français reste assez indifférent
à cette situation rev lui une bonne
popularité voilà même s'il a quand même
une bonne popularité qu'il est bien
accueilli qui suscite assez peu de
mécontentement ce qui est quand même un
signe voilà il y a quand même une
indifférence mais là où pour rebondir un
peu sur ce que vous disiez clairement ce
qu'ils attendent c'est du résultat pour
l'instant ils ont le sentiment que
Gabriel hatal est volontaire est
dynamique va peut-être changer les
choses il a marqué des points au
ministère de l'Éducation nationale dans
l'opinion parce que les gens ont
l'impression qu'il a beaucoup agi en
quelques mois donc ça montre que voilà
la communication a fonctionné mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent on leur a
demandé ils attendent des choses sur le
pouvoir d'achat et c'est vraiment le
sujet qui écrase mais de très très loin
tous les autres donc effectivement en
fonction de ce qui va avoir lieu comme
mesures des premières annonces de ce qui
va être fait potentiellement ils peuvent
être beaucoup plus critiques à l'égard
même du Premier ministre alors il y a un
autre ministre qui est confirmé c'est
Gérald daranin au ministère de
l'Intérieur est-ce que du coup on peut
pas se demander s'il y a une forme
d'injustice Élisabeth bande s'en va et
Gérald Darmanin reste or le patquè sur
la loi immigration il doit au moins
autant à lui qu'à elle est-ce qu'il y a
une forme d'injustice pour c'est pas la
lecture qu'on a fait qu'on a faite
Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il
a été intervoué dans dans cet avou
Emmanuel Macron vraiment il a donné un
bon point à Gérald daranin et mauvais
point à Elisabeth born j'ai d'ailleurs
pas très bien compris
pour personne n'a compris pourquoi c'est
très injuste pour Elisabeth born ce qui
est arrivé tuer son chien on dit qu'il a
la rage et et je je pense que ça peut
être aussi matinée de de sexisme c'estàd
que c'est toujours la femme qui qui
prend pour alors que les hommes sont
tout aussi responsables de de la
situation après la différence aussi
c'est que Gérald Harman a un poids
politique plus important que celui
d'éabeth borne au sens de il a un
ancrage territor fort à tourcoin dont il
a été le maire et en plus de ça il a un
petit groupe de de parlementaires
notamment de de députés que n'a pas
Elizabeth borne
il a des ambitions que n'avait pas
elliisabeth Bornet d'ailleurs si on
regarde trois noms qui sont confirmés
que ce soit Bruno Lemire on en parlait
que ce soit Gérald daranin mais que ce
soit aussi Sébastien nocordu ces trois
noms qui étaient pressentis à un moment
pour Matignon est-ce que ça va être
compliqué pour gabrielal de se retrouver
autour de autour de autour de la table
avec des gens qui auraient pu avoir sa
place et qui l'ont vu les dépasser et
qui ont négocié encore une fois avec le
président en direct euh moi je crois que
ça va être très difficile pour lui euh
parce que il on justement peut-être son
jeune âge là peut être un inconvénient
c'està dire un certain manque quand même
d'expérience pour manier comme on dit on
dit autrefois les éléphants hein au PS
en tout cas des des des poids lourds qui
encore une fois un acc direct au
président en fait il y a encore on reste
dans l'EN même temps finalement hein
c'est-à-dire
uel Macron a dit régénération je sais
plus ce qu'elle était
son physique mais on reste dans le en
même temps d'ailleurs vous avez été
discret sur le maintien de du pont morti
on va y venir on va y ven mais par
définition c'est bien toujours le en
même temps par rapport à Darmanin c'est
toujours justice police voyez ce que je
veux dire bon et donc on reste quand
même toujours dans cette ambigué sur les
questions sécuritaires sur sur vous les
trouvez pas sur la même ligne ah non il
sont pas sur la même ligne on s'en est
aperçu sur sur de nombreux sujets en
matière notamment de justice des mineurs
bon sur la politique pénale après les
émeutes urbaines toutes les consignes
qui ont été passé par le G des sa é qu
grand la de grandes demandes des
policiers relayé par Darmanin c'est la
réforme de l'ordonnance de 45 sur les
mineurs pour régler deux problèmes la
délinquence générale des mineurs la
violence seuellement et le fameux
problème des mineurs isolés et de ce
côté-là il y a un blocage du côté de la
place vendau
qui est quand même aussi garant de
l'État de droit notre garde des sa je
rentre je parle uniquement de politique
hein je parle pas de de morale c'est ce
qui me différen c'est pas de la morale
c'est l'état de droit non l'État de
droit n'est pas l'état du droit
exactement voilà donc l'état de droit
n'est pas l'état du droit donc on peut
faire évoluer comme le font des pays qui
sont tout à fait dans l'État de droit on
peut faire évoluer sa législation comme
nous avons fait évoluer la nôtre bon sur
tout un tas de sujets donc tout en
restant dans l'État de droit en tout cas
il y a une discussion et un débat et un
en même temps entre ces deux je crois je
crois qu'Emmanuel Macron il faudra
peut-être un jour se poser la question à
à peut-être un problème à vraiment
bouger à changer à évoluer à choisir à
fixer un cap et qui reste
fondamentalement attaché à son logiciel
de départ qui est son logiciel regardez
les hésitations quand même la nomination
de Gabriel Atal ça pas été facile la
nomination de gouvernement elle a l'air
pas facile et j'ai pas personne n
l'impression dans les commentaires enfin
j'entends pas que c'est parce que
Emmanuel Macron est le maître des
horloges non
Gabriel natal on peut le rappeler a été
nommé mardi nous sommes jeudi oui mais
on a connu des des gouvernement plus
long plus long accoucher lundi lundi ça
va non mais ça a duré le nombre de jours
où on attendait si ellizabeth borne
allait partir quand est-ce que une
semaine puisque le Conseil des ministrre
a été annulé la semaine dernière en
général vous avez le nom du premier
ministre qui remplace beaucoup plus vite
vous vous l'avez vous l'avez dans la
journée oui là on on a attendu et
surtout ça a duré et on sent très bien
vous vous souvenez de tous ces
rendez-vous d'Élisabeth borne allant à
l'élyisée plusieurs fois
des ministres encore une fois non le
processus en éz quand même vous
connaissez bien la vie politique
française n'a pas été facile non c'est
toujours une
équationli pas toujours le cas enfin
souvent le cas avec Emmanuel Macron qui
a allongé cette durée et ça de Premier
ministre en premier ministre ét plus
simple avec de plus en plus long à
mesure autres pr minist résolution en
tout cas c'est comme ça qu'il est perçu
dans l'opinion sentiment qu' il n' plus
sour humaines commenton il a
énormément il a énormément perdu sur ses
points forts qui étaient déterminés je
sais où je vais et cetera quand on
regarde il sait où il va c'est un des
traits d'images comme on dit dans notre
jargon qui a le plus baissé et on sent
chez les français quand même le
sentiment depuis son deuxème quinena un
peu de flou il se demande un peu quelle
est la vision et quel est le cap
politique donc effectivement ça ça se ça
transparit dans les enquêtes il y a un
nouveau nom Tam celui de Priska tevno
oui Priska tevnoau qui a été
porte-parole de renaissance qui a été
élu député des hautes scènes et qui
était bien entre guillemets sous la
coupe de Gabriel hatal lorsque il était
ministre de l'éducation nationale
puisque elle s'occupait du
euhicetion du SNU univ un dossier qui
n'est pas encore tranché pour le coup
est-ce que ce que ce service proposé aux
jeunes va être généralisé ou est-ce
qu'il va être facultatif tout à fait
c'est une question qu'on a posé
plusieurs fois à tous les ministres qui
se sont occupés de ça RA Gabri Gabri S
et puis priscat et priscat donc j'ai
commencé en disant qu'elle avait déjà
été porte-parole de renaissance parce
que c'est aussi comme ça qu'on l'a
découverte assez à l'aise à l'époque sur
les plateaux de télévision et c'est ce
qui lui a valu au fur et à mesure ses
ses promotion bon là devenir
porte-parole du gouvernement c'est quand
même une sacrée marche mais voilà c'est
le premier nom de femme que nous
connaissons dans pour l'instant un panel
qui est très très masculin et où elle
nitt entre guillemets mais que
porte-parole alors qu'on connaît quand
même les poids lourds sur d'autres
ministères moi si je peux ajouter sur ce
que ce qui vient d'être dit
priscatevenou en fait exactement comme
Gabriel Atal en fait ils sont nommés en
fonction de leur proximité avec pour
Gabriel Atal proximité avec Emmanuel
Macron priscatevau proximité avec
Gabriel Atal ce qui ce qui est un petit
souci hein ça peut arriver parfois en
politique je dis pas que ça c'est je dis
pas que ça ça pe il peut arriver à des
présidents de nommer des
proches au gouvernement tout à fait mais
ça veut dire que l'arbitrage ne s'est
pas fait pour des raisons politiques il
se fait pour des raisons de bon bah
c'est mon proche il m'est loyal il y a
il y a qu'à entendre le nombre de fois
que Gabriel hatal dans son discours sur
le pon de Matignon a cité et remercier
Emmanuel Macron il a je crois que c'est
arrivé trois fois et au bout d'un moment
c'est bon on a compris c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui mais Renaissance c'est un
parti où il y a pas de courant donc il y
a pas de ligne politique
qui' était différent si un premier
ministre modem ou horizon qui sont des
alliés de renaissance av é un grand
saladier dans lequel tout le monde tombe
et puis tout le monde finit par dire la
même chose sans tenir de ligne politique
c'estàd qu'onarbitre pas entre tout à
l'heure Christophe parlait de éc Dupont
Moretti et Géral darbanin c'est vrai
qu'il y a une opposition dans la vision
de ce que c'est que l'État dans la
vision de ce que doit être la sécurité
française mais je crois que c'est à peu
près le seul endroit où dans le
gouvernement vous avez des des tensions
et des lignes politiques qui sont un
tout petit peu différentes ce qui est un
problème ce qui est un problème puisque
le
pvez pas avelun qui soit leage
parfinitionez êtreole de tout le monde
moi je crois que là là il y a un
problème compétence qu' bien vu quand
même Emmanuel Macron gabrielal était un
excellent
porte-parole Olivier verrant je parle
vraiment de qualité technique j'enseigne
la rhtorique à sciencep Olivier verrant
est un bon rhtoricien elle est bonne en
rhtorique donc je pense aussi que là ce
qui compte c'est d'avoir quelqu'un en
effet du proche du président qui est pas
de qui ne soit pas dans un clage
justement parce qu'il doit défendre il
soit capable de faire preuve de
pédagogie et pu porter le fer contre
l'opposition avec des punch il doit
défendre à la fois du poriti et daranin
donc je pense que le choix n n'est pas
mauvais Christel crappel la popularité
de Gabriel Atal vous nous disiez c'est
58 % 58 % là on l'a mesuré juste au
moment de sa nomination donc il la
popularité d'Emmanuel Macron 32 % est-ce
qu'on a déjà vu un couple exécutif comme
on dit aussi dissonnant en terme de de
sondage bah quand Elisabeth borne a été
nommée nominé nommé pardon elle était à
50 % donc là le clivage est très fort
mais c'est aussi parce qu'il y a un
effet il vient d'être nommé il a été il
é très très populaire donc là il y a un
écart très important il faut quand même
qu'on voit si cet écart dur parce que on
observe on va on appelle ça avant on
appelait ça l'état de grâce aujourd'hui
ça dure quand même très très peu que ce
soit Édouard Philippe jean- Castex enfin
tous tous les premiers ministres ont vu
leur popularité diminuer très très vite
en l'espace de 2 3 mois là c'est un peu
différent parce qu'il arrive avec une
popularité donc elle est pas seulement
porté par la
nouveauté il arrive pardon à voir si
voilà ça ça dure dans le temps alors
comment le président de la République et
sont nouveau Premier ministre vont-ils
se répartir les rôles comment vont-ils
articuler leur prise de parole on va en
parler avec vous Tam puisque Ben Gabriel
Atal devrait faire on imagine un
discours de politique générale il y a
pas choix c'est normal c'est le boulot
c'est pas obligatoire mais c'est c'est
en tout cas la tradition le problème
c'est que dans le même temps Emmanuel
Macron lui aussi a donné rendez-vous
avec de rendez-vous au citoyens pour un
rendez-vous avec la nation qu'on n pas
forcément d'ailleurs très bien compris
mais il y a quand même une question qui
se pose qui va parler en premier alors
deux hypothèses he quand on n pas la
réponse on échafaud des hypothèses alors
soit c'est Gabriel Atal qui parle en
premier et là et bien il a deux mauvais
choix soit il dit il en dit trop soit il
n'en dit pas assez je m'explique soit il
vient dévoiler une partie de ce qui'est
ce grand rendez-vous avec la nation et
donc il coupe l'herbe sous le pied
d'Emmanuel Macron soit et bien il est
coincé par ce discours avec venir du
chef de l'État il ne peut pas le
dévoiler ce qui donne une déclaration de
politique générale sans doute plus
pauvre ou un petit peu corseté deuxième
hypothèse on inverse l'ordre ça serait
plus simple ça serait sans doute plus
simple effectivement c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui prend la parole en premier il
a pas beaucoup de temps pour le faire
puisque le discours de politique
générale c'est pour la semaine prochaine
normalement en tout cas c'est ce qu'on a
vu dans l'ordre du jour qui semble avoir
été nettoyé au Parlement et là à nen pas
doutter ça sera interprété comme une
façon de tenir la bride courte à son
premier ministre ça serait pourtant pas
la première fois qu'un président de la
République grille d'une certaine façon
la politesse à son premier ministre oui
surtout pour Emmanuel Macron la
situation s'est déjà présentée au début
du premier quinquenat d'Emmanuel Macron
lorsque le président de la République
choisit de convoquer on se le rappelle
tous le Parlement réuni en congrès à
Versailles exactement la veille du jour
où le nouveau Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe doit s'exprimer pour la
première fois devant l'Assemblée
nationale pour son discours de politique
générale et certains médias se demandent
alors si c'est une humiliation pour le
nouveau locataire de Matignon si c'est
le signe qu'il va justement avoir cette
fameuse bride courte s'il ne va pas y
avoir de téllescopage entre les deux la
vérité c'est que finalement les deux
vont s'enchaîner avec chacun sa
partition pour le premier bien les
grandes orientations pour les 5 ans à
venir les heures de Versailles
qu'Emmanuel Macron a tente affectionné
au début de son premier mandat bref une
sorte de grand discours sur l'état de
l'Union en référence à la pratique
américaine et pour Édouard Philippe
promess de réforme constitutionnelle je
me souviens ou tout à fait et alors dans
le discours de politique et Édouard
Philippe le discours de la méthode un
discours politique d'exécution des
annonces très concrètes j'ai révisé très
concrètes sur le budget sur la réforme
du bac sur les vaccins obligatoires et
même le prix du paquet de cigarettes à
10 € à l'époque il a même le luxe de
pouvoir demander le vote de confiance
remporté au la main puisque autre temps
autres équilibres le gouvernement
dispose alors d'une majorité écrasante à
l'Assemblée alors vous avez commencé par
deux hypothèses tout à l'heure mais il y
en aurait même une troisième et oui
parce que vous avez commencé en le
disant le le grand rendez-vous avec la
nation on sait pas vraiment ce que c'est
la question a été posée d'ailleurs à
l'Élysée mardi comment va s'articuler ce
grand rendez-vous annoncé depuis le mois
de décembre par Emmanuel Macron et le
remanement que nous vivons donc et la
réponse de l'Élysée c'est que ce
rendez-vous ce n'est pas une soirée
entre Emmanuel Macron et les Français ce
n'est pas un verre avec le président de
la République mais c'est un processus il
paraîtrait même que nous sommes déjà
dedans nous sommes déjà en rendez-vous
donc avec le président de la République
mais lui seul a l'air de le voir bah
peut-être que l'Élysée les communicurs
d'élysée faisait savoir qu'il voulait
organiser ce rendez-vous avec la nation
façon série Netflix peut-être que le
premier
épisode nation il fait de la pro sans le
savoir nous on est déjà dans son grand
événement et on ne sa sait pas nous
sommes je disais tout à l'heure c'est
pas obligatoire le discours de politique
générale euh Elisabeth borne n'avait pas
fait de vote de confiance avait-elle
fait un
discours avait même fondu l'ARM toute la
question ça va être la question du vote
ou pas d'ailleurs parce que on voit mal
on voit mal comment ça peut se faire il
va évidemment faire un discours de
politique générale et vous avez tout à
fait raison et c'est pour ça que en
opportunité on comprend mal cette
séquence si on veut faire un comment un
réarmement euh appelez-moi dans quel
processus nous sommes ça réarmement
régénérationà si on veut faire ça mais
c'était au président de parler tout de
suite en disant voilà mon réarmement et
je nomme donc Gabriel àal et je nomme
une nouvelle équipe régénérée et cetera
or là on est à l'envers c'està-dire on
commence par donc tout ce balaai autour
de elliisabeth borne va-telle rester je
vous rappelle quand même qu'il y a une
semaine il y avait des des rumeurs en ce
sens puis Gabriel àal puis des poids
lourds qui restent puis on ne sait plus
qui vous voulez dire ça un sentiment
d'improvisation ah moi je sens je crois
pas être le seul je sens qu'il y a les
Français semble-t-il enfin je rejoint un
peu l'opinion majoritaire parce que je
la sens et parce que je l'entends quand
on parle avec les gens qu'il y a une
sorte de perte de de main quand même
losing his grip comme disent les angis
Pablo le vote de confiance il est
réclamé par les oppositions notamment
par la gauche mais c'est pas obligatoire
oui non c'est pas obligatoire ils sont
pas obligés de le faire d'ailleurs moi
je je suis pas d'accord avec Christophe
je je pense que il aurait tout intérêt à
le faire puisque d'ors et déjà on sait
très bien que les LR et le rassemblement
national ils ont dit peu ou prou que il
s'abstiendrai ou même enfin voilà ça les
intéresse pas sur un vote de confiance
donc globalement il il ne risque pas d'y
avoir de majorité lesr sont-ils fiables
exactement exactement et même et et même
le rassemblement national hein sur le
vote de la loi immigration ils avaient
dit que non et puis finalement oui ils
ont voté pour mais moi juste j'aimerais
revenir sur ce ce ce grand événement là
cette grande cette grande rencontre
grand processus avec avec les Français
dans lequel nous sommes déjà moi j'ai un
peu et même sur cette nomination sur
toutes ces nominations là vous avez
parlé de série Netflix je pense que
c'est exactement ça qui sont en train
d'essayer de faire c'estàd que ils nous
font des surprises moi je je je ne
savais pas en fait que faire de la
politique c'était faire des surprises
parce que ce grand rendez-vous avec les
français Emmanuel Macron l'annonce
depuis le mois de septembre non depuis
le 8 décembre non non non non non non
non il avit fait une interview il avait
fait une interview au tout début de
l'année à la rentrée scolaire dans
lequel il avait déjà parlé de ce grand
rendez-v en tout cas c'est dans le
journal Le Monde le 8 décembre dernier
qui parle d'un rendez-vous avec la
nation exement mais il a il l' préc
enfin il l'a précisé entre guillemets
mais tout ça enfin des surprises mais
depuis quand en fait les Français et les
Françaises attendent des surprises ils
attendent des soit-disant ils attendent
des surprises dans les nominations alors
on avoir des prise alors à la culture à
je sais pas quoi aux anciens combattants
voilà super on va avoir des surprises
des gens vraiment extraordinaires qui
vont être nommés là on attend une
surprise sur ce processus qui va nous
qui va nous dévoiler non les Français
ils attendent pas des surprises la
politique c'est pas faire des surprises
la politique c'est pas mettre du
suspense pour que pour tenir les gens en
haline la politique c'est donner des
Caps clairs et produire en fait de la
ligne politique pour que enfin on puisse
on puisse se projeter se reconnaître
dans dans quelque chose parce que sinon
c'est le foutoir alors Christelle
précisément qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent
les français si on fixe une forme de
priorité des Français vis-à-vis de ce
nouveau gouvernement bah ils attendent
surtout des résultats en fait peu
importe un peu les figures politiques le
les noms tout ça leur passe largement
au-dessus de la tête ce qu'ils veulent
c'est des résultats dans le domaine
principal qui les intéresse comme je
disais tout à l'heure le pouvoir d'achat
mais aussi sur l'éducation la santé la
santé un sujet très important pour eux
et et ce qu'ils veulent c'est des
résultats et c'est toute la le problème
de de la politique ces dernières années
c'est ce qui fait aussi qu'il s'en
éloignent de plus en plus c'est qu'ils
ont le sentiment que finalement rien ne
change concrètement dans leur quotidien
donc à quoi bon et c'est ce qui
expliqueune partie d'entre eux ben ne va
plus voter ou extrêmement défiant à
l'égard du du personnel politique alors
deux deux nouveaux noms que je que que
je vous donne alors je rappelle que ce
n'est pas la communication officielle du
secrétaire général de l'Élysée he mais
que ce sont des sources médiatiques avec
une ministre de la Culture qui pourrait
être Rachida
Dati et une ministre de l'éducation
nationale vous savez l'école ce dossier
que Gabriel Attal avait dit vouloir
emmener avec lui en tout cas par
l'esprit à Matignon serait confié à
l'actuel ministre des Sports Amélie ouea
Castera qui verrait son portefeuille
élergie en plus des sports une réaction
sur Rachid hadti c'est c'est c'est une
prise de guerre chez les républicains
alors écoutez j'ai un peu de mal à enfin
on a on a voilà une surprise comme
dirait notre ami Pablo non je pense que
là je il faudrait vraiment faire une
quadrature du cercle très rapide pour
essayer de comprendre ce qui peut
motiver le président ça on le voit ce
qui peut la motiver elle c'estàd ce qui
peut motiver le président
ditlicitement pu pas n'importe laquelle
c'est quand même une figure
éminente des républicains et super
médiatique et super médiatique elle est
connue hein depuis son passage au
ministère de la Justice elle a pas
quitté le le devant de la scène en plus
elle joue une opposition très forte à
anidalgo à Paris donc elle ne quitte pas
l'attention générale en tout cas à Paris
maintenant je je vois mal son inérêt
mais peut-être que je ne suis pas assez
politique ou assez politicien pour le
comprendre et j'attends vraiment
confirmation pour l'autre portefeuille
ça me paraît très important parce que
euh Gabriel Atal ne peut pas se
permettre d'erreur sur la question de
l'éducation parce qu'il a suscité
beaucoup d'attentes euh et c'est pour ça
qu'il a dit j'emmène la cause avec moi
hein mais encore faut-il qu'il précise
comment euh alors une ministre qui va
devoir gérer les Jeux Olympiques
et en même temps l'éducation nationale
qui est quand même un un mamouth
rappelez-vous la qui est la PH de claud
ça fait beaucoup de boulot pour24 ça
fait beaucoup de boulot est-ce que ça
veut dire que justement il faut vraiment
envoyer des signes très clairs hein
est-ce que ça veut justement dire que du
coup elle s'occupera surtout des Jeux
Olympiques et que le premier ministre
continuera à s'occuper de l'éducation
nationale en tout cas ça va demander une
clarification et encore comme disait
très bien Pablo il faut fixer un peu des
caps et puis dire qui fait quoi mais
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on fait Pablo quand
on a deux priorités c'est qu'on en a
aucune eu oui je pense j' c'est vraiment
très très bien très très bien résumé
surtout lorsque c'est ces priorités
parfois sont un peu orthogonales donc
les sport l'éducation c'est pas
forcément orthogonal non c'est c'est pas
orthogonal mais l'agenda voilà c'est ça
au bout d'un moment recevoir tous les
syndicats de profs et puis après
s'occuper de la sécurité des Jos je suis
désolé mais c'est à mon à mon avis
incompatible pour une seule et et même
personne et ensuite sur l'hypothèse qui
est soulevée par Christophe de dire bon
bah peut-être que c'est Gabriel Premier
ministre qui s'en occupera je ne le vois
pas non plus recevoir et gérer par le
menu tout ce qu'il faut faire avec
encore une fois les syndicats de de
professeurs qui sont des syndicats qui
sont très constitués qui sont très
puissants dans le parmi le corps
professoral donc non c'est c'est
absolument pas gérable et même la
première chose c'est que moi je je je
prends le Paris que si effectivement
c'est améliie oua casterra qui qui est
nommé à la tête de ce de ce grand
ministère les syndicats de prof vont
dire non mais on se on se moque de nous
on se moque de nous on nous met la
ministre des Sports qui doit gérer les
Jeux Olympiques et on va plus s'occuper
de nous et est vraiment l'éducation
devient le cadette de et les parents
d'élèves et l'opinion enfin il y a un
risque aussi voilà que il y a comme je
disais tout à l'heure il y a eu
énormément d'attentes et Gabriel Atal a
répondu à ses attentes que moi ça m'a
frappé quand on regarde les dans dans
des questions spontanées les gens disent
moi j'apprécie Gabriel hatal parce que
pourtant il était que quelques mois mais
il a agi sur l'éducation il a marqué les
esprits sur le tellement sur la laïcité
donc il a suscité des attentes et ça
peut donner le sentiment finalement bah
que tout ça n'a duré qu'un temps et que
derrière le dossier n'est pas suivi
puisqu'on met quelqu'un qui a déjà un
autre portefeuille donc ça peut aussi
être un peu risqué il y a d'énormes
attentes entre la la réforme du brévet
les groupes de niveau au collège la fin
du redoublement il y a énormément de
choses très concrètes qui qu'il a
annoncé et enfin l'un des l'une des
faiblesses quand même de Gabriel at
c'est que jusqu'ici il est resté trop
peu de temps que ce soit
au budget lorsqu'il a annoncé son plan
sur la fraude là à l'éducation nationale
pour qu'on puisse réellement vérifier sa
capacité d'action et de réalisation de
ce qu'il avait annoncé c'est un ministre
zappeur oui un peu comme l'air du temps
zppé zaapé promu là pour le
coup oui je je vois aussi une autre
échéance quand on parle des pour aller
dans dans votre sens il y a une chose
qu'on oublie toujours ça m'étonne un peu
d'ailleurs vous savez que le 25 janvier
je crois le Conseil constitutionnel doit
se prononcer sur la loi immigration al
il y a aussi des attentes de l'opinion
dans ce domaine imaginons que le Conseil
constitutionnel ce qui à mon avis n'est
pas impossible surtout que son président
vient d'être chassé de la mémoire
collective comme le plus jeune premier
ministre de France il est possible que
le Conseil constitutionnel soit soit
sévère et détricote beaucoup la loi en
tout cas le le président du Conseil
constitutionnel Laurent Fabius a fait la
leçon à Emmanuel Macron le lundi dernier
lors des traditionnels vœux du président
de la République au Conseil
constitutionnel précisément sur cette
question en disant que le Conseil consti
titionnelle n'était pas une chambre
d'appel du Parlement ni une chambre
d'éco de l'opinion mais que ça devait
être la Constitution sais parce que ça
peut vouloir dire deux choses he ou il
va avaliser ou il va au contraire et mon
avis il est plutôt plôt remonter comme
vous le dites vous-même imaginons qu'il
déricote beaucoup cette loi B la
question de l'imigration on revient à
zéro c'est-à-dire que le sujet ne
disparaît pas voyez ce que je dire à
Gabriel Atal ne peut pas dire ah bon ben
c'est c'est fini on parle on passe à
autre chose le sujet de l'immigration du
coup il va devoir le traiter et on va
retomber dans ce cauchemar pour la
macronie de TR ce sujet qui on le sait
divise non pas comme on le dit toujours
le Parlement mais la macronie elle-même
le texte peut être dépouillé de tous les
ajouts que qu'on fait les républicains
mais certaines mesures peuvent rester et
puis un gouvernement peut zapper en
considérant que c'est plus le moment là
pour le coup ça s vu ça s vu non je dis
juste que ça s'est vu par le passé quand
des textes avent provoqué des grandes
frur a quand même une promesse à tenir
c'est le débat sur laame sur l'aide
médicale métat on le rappelle les
républicains voul transformation de
l'aide médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence dans le texte sur
l'immigration Elisabeth borne qui était
alors Premier ministre l'avait retiré du
texte mais leur avait promis pas un
courrier adressé notamment à Gérard
Larcher qu'une réforme serait engagée
dès le début de l'année sur la base du
rapport qui lui avait été remis par
l'ancien ministre socialiste claudévin
de la santé et puis l'ancien voilà
Patrick
Stéphani l'ancien préfet et puis
l'ancien proche de de de Nicolas Sarkozi
mais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça va
devenir cette cette ab est-ce qu'elle
n'engage que son auteur et donc est-ce
que Gabriel Atal peut s'en laver les
mains Pablo je je pense pas qu'il puisse
s'en laver les mains parce que c'est
quand même un accord un espèce de deal
qui avait été fait entre les LR et le le
gouvernement alors certes le
gouvernement a a changé mais pas ça sa
ligne politique je rappelle aussi que
cette question de la M c'était aussi une
des raisons pour lesquelles Aurélien
Rousseau la l'ancien ministre de la
Santé avait dit non non moi je reste pas
parce que je ne veux pas être le
ministre qui réduit le périmètre parce
que cette transformation de l'aide
médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence c'est une réduction du
périmètre de de de l'aide médicale il a
dit je ne veux pas être le ministre qui
qui qui
effectuera cette infamie hein qui est
dénoncé d'ailleurs par franchement
presque l'ensemble des personnels
soignants donc je je il va falloir qu'il
nomme parce que ça on en a pas parlé il
va falloir qu'il nomme un ministre ou
une ministre de la Santé qui soit
capable de de de tenir la plume pour
modifier laame contre la vie des de tous
les médecins qui a et de tous les
personnels soignants qui l' le le
rapport dont je parlais proposait des
pistes de réforme qui n'étaent pas celle
des républicains d'ailleurs oui mais bon
ça juste Christelle on on a on a
beaucoup dit au moment de du vote de la
loi qu'elle était soutenue que les
mesures que portait cette loi
immigration étaé soutenue par les
français si la loi est détricotée par le
Conseil constitutionnel est-ce qu'on
peut avoir une opinion qui qui qui qui
qui en sortirait froissé il y a deux
choses parce que la loi a été soutenue
mais également les mesures qui n'ont pas
été retenues notamment la régularit des
travailleurs sans papier qui était aussi
soutenu donc les les Français avaient
une vision un peu plus large que les les
les parlementaires en revanche ça peut
donner le sentiment que d'impuissance en
fait que finalement on vote une loi mais
après elle est détcoter même si c'est
pour des raisons constitutionnell tout à
fait recevable dans l'opinion ça peut
être perçu comme un élément
d'impuissance et ben finalement ça ne
sert à rien la politique et bah donner
du grain à moudre à ce rejet de de la
chose politique qu'on et en particulier
un parti qui joue sur ce sur ce Crau
nous on veut changer la constition
présidenton entend
aussi vrai avec un vrai risque de
déstabilisation des institutions à
commencé par le Conseil constitutionnel
qui va être décrié on va dire bah voilà
il est contre ce que pensent les
Français et cetera et d'ailleurs comme
vous l'avez dit le rassemblement
national est déjà en train de dire que
de toute façon Conseil constitutionnel
faudrait le supprimer et et et même on
entend il parle pas de supprimer le
Conseil
constitutionnel su je vais encore plus
loin que ce qu'il
propose changer la Constitution pour en
réduire le pouvoir de façon drastique
mais c'est peu ou prou ce qu'a dit aussi
comment Gérard Larcher le président du
Sénat lui il a pas dit qu'il voulait
supprimer du tout le Conseil
constitutionnel mais il a dit bon ben on
changera la Constitution ça peut se
changer une constitution oui mais oui
mais le problème c'est que si on
commence à changer en fait tout ce qui
fonde en fait nos institutions ça ça
c'est un débat la Constitution n'est pas
forcément intouchable elle doit être
appliquée et on pe
avant avant de terminer ce débat est-ce
que ce gouvernement en tout cas les noms
qui sont donnés et puis la présence de
Gabriel Atal à Matignon en fond un
gouvernement de combat pour les
européennes puisque c'est une démission
de Gabriel Atal c'est essayer de de de
de mener cette campagne de du camp
présidentiel pour les européennes
christop j'ai l'impression que du coup
enfin je vais peut-être j'ai
l'impression que Gabriel Atal va surtout
servir à ça CIT lui-même c'est-à-dire le
fameux match que que le gouvernement a
bien lancé là Emmanuel Macron l'a bien
l'a bien bien profilé les médias
évidemment aiment beaucoup ça le match
bardellaa à tal et qui me rappelle je
suis le doyen du plateau donc qui me
rappelle l'époque où Laurent Fabius
ferraillit avec le chef de l'opposition
qui à l'époque était Jacques Chirac hein
vous n'étiez personne n'était né moi
j'étais là et je peux vous dire que
c'est un peu quelque chose qui car
Emmanuel Macron a une grande mémoire
mitérandienne c'est un peu quelque chose
qui pourrait se profiler c'est-à-dire
instauré et là je vois là je vois
vraiment le rôle de Gabriel Atal face à
à Jordane Bardella dans la mesure où
surtout c'est toujours pas très bien qui
va diriger la liste macronienne aux
Européennes en tout cas Gabriel ATA lui
pèse lourd et là je pense que c'est
peut-être le vrai combat dont il sera
chargé et peut-être le seul combat
Christel Atal Bardella c'est un match
aussi dans l'opinion ce sont deux
personnalités populaires c'est deux
personnalités populaire là depuis que
Gabriel Atal est passé Premier ministre
du coup il n'est plus dans notre tableau
de personnalité effectivement Jordane
Bardella est en 3e position et c'est une
vraie figure identifiée et montante et
on dit que les deux sont populaires
notamment dans l'électorat jeune qui est
pas forcément celui qui vote le plus
mais auprès des jeunes notamment oui
alors c'est peut-être un peu plus vrai
pour Jordane bardela pour le coup que
pour Gabriel Atal qui là j'avais regardé
les résultats faisait un carton plutôt
chez les seniors en l'occurrence comme
quoi on peut être jeune et plaire au
moins jeune quelque chose qui avait
notamment réussi un certain Emmanuel
Macron bien ben merci à tous c'est la
fin de ce premier débat merci d'y avoir
participé